- [Kim] Hi, this is Kim from Khan Academy.
Today we're learning more
about the takings clause
of the Fifth Amendment.
In another video, we'll
discuss the other clauses
of the Fifth Amendment, those that deal
with self-incrimination
and due process of law
but in this video, we're
concentrating on just
the last few words of the Fifth Amendment
which forbid the government
from taking private property
for public use without just compensation.
To learn more about the takings clause,
I sought out the help of two experts.
Richard Epstein is the Laurence
A. Tisch professor of law
and director of the Classical
Liberal Institute at NYU law.
He's also a senior fellow
at the Hoover Institution.
Eduardo Penñalver is the
Allan R. Tessler professor
and dean of Cornell Law School.
So Profess Epstein, can you
give us a little background,
just what is the takings clause?
- [Richard] Well there's a
rule in constitutional law
that the shorter the
provision, the more difficult
the interpretation and this
is a very short petition.
It says, "nor shall private
property be taken for public use
"without just compensation,"
and the first thing to
understand about the clause
is that it's in the passive
voice so it doesn't tell you
who's taking it and early
on, since this was part
of the Bill of Rights,
it was said to apply only
to congress and not to
the states and then after
the Civil War through the 14th Amendment,
it was said to apply to the states.
So now it applies to both the states
and to the federal government.
- [Eduardo] Many constitutions don't have
an explicit property protection clause
but there is a fairly strong
norm around compensating
owners of private property
when you essentially commandeer
their property for public
purposes and that seems
to have been the motivation.
I think the clearest reading of it is
that it's a provision of the
Constitution that makes clear
that when the federal
government takes your property
or when the states take your property
for some public use that
they have to make you whole
by giving you just compensation.
- [Richard] Private property's
a pretty comprehensive term.
Everybody understands that it means land
and the things you build on land.
They also understand that
it tends to cover chattels,
that is things like books
and baseballs that you happen
to own and wild animals but it's also,
it's much broader than that.
It covers all sorts of intangible rights
like patents, copyrights, trade secrets.
These are very complicated
and generally speaking,
the government doesn't have any obligation
to create a patent but once
it gives you the patent,
it just can't take it from
you because the patent,
after conferred, it is
in fact a property right
and then it also may or may not cover
other kinds of intangibles
like good will which is
the value associated with a business
knowing that your past
customers may come back
to you in the future.
- [Eduardo] On the motives of the framers
for including this, talk about things like
the confiscation, mostly
of personal property
during the Revolutionary War
by the British government
that that was possibly a
motivation to make clear
that if in future scenarios,
if the government wanted
to take your property, it
would have to compensate you.
Most historians don't think
there was a real problem
being addressed by this, a
problem of uncompensated taking
of property by colonial governments
during that period or
by the state governments
during the Articles of Confederation.
- [Richard] The framers wanted a system
of what we'd call limited government
and so what the takings
clause essentially says
is yes we need your land for fort
and it's really very important
but if we're gonna take
it and use it for fort,
that's a public use, we're
gonna pay you compensation
for the fair market
value of the land before
the fort was put on and this is in order
to make sure that you
can't pick and choose
your victims and it's a way
of assuring government regularity.
That's the first.
Second thing is more economic,
less apparent at the time
of the framing, pretty apparent today,
is that the government can take something
and not pay you compensation,
it's gonna overtake.
So your land is worth 100
thousand dollars as a farm
but if you're gonna use it for a fort,
it's only worth 10 thousand dollars.
If you don't have to pay
the 100 thousand dollars,
well you may take it 'cause
you get 10 thousand dollars
worth of gain but if you have
to pay the fair market value
of the property interest
taking, you won't do it.
So essentially what it
does is it makes sure
or at least improves the
odds that when the government
does take property, what
does regular, it will in fact
improve overall social welfare.
So you have a political function dealing
with singling out and you
have an economic function
dealing with the overall improvement
of government behavior from
an economic point of view.
- [Kim] Okay so say I had a piece of land
and the government decided
that they wanted it
for some purpose, what
would be the legal process
for the government to go
about acquiring my land?
- [Eduardo] Well the
process for eminent domain
really varies by state but
typically there's some notice
that the government
gives you that it intends
to take your property.
The government goes to
court and gets an order
of condemnation to take
title of the property
and then often there's a requirement
that the government bargained with you
about the value of the property.
It will tell you what
it thinks the value is,
the fair market value is
the standard that we use
for just compensation,
that's the value that
a willing buyer would
pay to a willing seller
for the land.
It doesn't include things
like your sentimental value
or anything like that so
it's just the market value
of the property.
There's some back and forth
through this required bargaining.
If the government and the property owner
can't reach an agreement
then the government
can go to court and get
the court to specify
the value of the property
that will be paid
in compensation and
then the payment is made
and the deed is transferred
and the government
becomes the owner of the property.
- [Kim] Interesting, so the government
has gone through this process
to try to acquire my land,
what if I'm a real holdout
and I just really don't want
the government to get my
land, what happens then?
- [Eduardo] Well you can
litigate the various pieces
of this and again, it depends
a little bit on the state law.
So some states put more
procedural hurdles in the way
of the government.
Other states make it
easier for the government
but under the Constitution,
there are really only two ways
you can resist the taking of your property
through eminent domain.
One is by arguing that the
use that the government plans
to make of your property
doesn't count as legitimate
public use because the clause says,
"nor shall private property
be taken for public use
"without just compensation,"
and that public use language
has been interpreted
to be a limitation on the
power of eminent domain
and then you can argue, the
second thing you can argue
is that what the
government is offering you
in terms of just compensation
is not adequate compensation.
And you can litigate
those through the courts
and that can slow the
process down quite a bit.
Some states make it
easier for the government
by saying well the government
can actually just take title
while you're litigating
and others make you go...
Allow you to stop the condemnation process
and litigate in advance but
there's often what's called
a quick take procedure
which allows the government
to move more quickly
and put the litigation
on the backend but the
public use, if it's found,
if the use if found not
to be public, what you win
is an actual prohibition
on the taking itself.
You keep your property.
If you win on the just compensation side,
all you get is more money,
they still take your property.
- [Kim] So you mentioned public use.
What counts as public use?
- [Eduardo] Well under the current law,
any use that generates a public benefit
is really a public use.
The way the court has put it
is anything the government,
any purpose the government can pursue
through any other means, it can pursue
through eminent domain.
So if the government wants to create jobs
or if the government wants to beautify
or if the government
wants to remove blight,
all those things are things
that we think it's legitimate
for the government to try to do.
If it can do those things,
it can do them through
the use of the eminent domain power.
- [Kim] One thing that
strikes me as interesting
is just the fact that this clause
is in the Fifth Amendment among things
like double jeopardy or self-incrimination
so why do you think the framers included
this particular clause here as opposed
to elsewhere in the Bill of Rights?
- [Richard] Well that's a great question
to which there's no obvious
answer but the one clause
that is pretty close to it
is the due process clause
in the Fifth Amendment that says,
"nor shall any person be deprived of life,
"liberty or property
without due process of law."
So if you start with the procedural stuff,
somebody's gonna say well how do we know
that the procedures aren't fair?
And if it turns out
that the government uses
a set of procedures that don't
give you adequate notice,
you're always going to end up short
on the amount of compensation
that you're gonna require.
So bad procedures tend
to lead to bad outcomes
which tend to lead to property being taken
at less than full market value.
So what happens is is
therefore very close linkage
between the procedures used
under the due process clause
and the substantive protection
that you have under takings.
- [Kim] Any changes in the interpretation
of the takings clause by
the Supreme Court over time?
- [Richard] Well there's
been a huge kind of switch up
and down and let me put
it the following way.
In the beginning, there
wasn't much of anything
that was done with respect
to the takings clause.
The first federal case to deal with it
was called Barron against
Baltimore in 1833 or so
and it just simply said that
the clause does not allow
for protection of Mr.
Barron against the city
of Baltimore because it only binds
the federal government,
it doesn't bind the state.
After the Civil War, two things happen,
a real distinction, the first
thing is you start getting
comprehensive regulation of the railroads
and the rates they can charge
and then public utilities
and the rates that they can charge.
And then in 1921, there's a
case called Block v. Hersch
and it's a very close 5-4 decision
but they sustain on the
grounds that it's a wartime,
a temporary two year statute
that limits the rents
that can be charged in Washington D.C.
at the end of the first World War.
- [Eduardo] One of the biggest changes
in the interpretation
of the takings clause
was the extension of the takings clause
to government situations
in which your property
was not appropriated by the government.
So what we call the
regulatory takings doctrine
which started in with the
case of Pennsylvania Coal
versus Mayhon in the 1920s
and then has now become
much more, it was sort
of dormant for a while
but become much more
active since the 1980s,
that's a doctrine that says,
"if the government regulates
your use of property
"excessively, then the
courts can treat that
"in effect as a confiscation
of your property
"and require the payment
of just compensation."
That's maybe the most significant change
in the interpretation of
the clause in its history.
So there continues to be controversy
about the public use doctrine
on modern commentators,
especially libertarians, who
want a very narrowly drawn
account of public use and
disagree with the breadth
of the doctrine as I described it to you.
So there's a lot of activism around that.
There's been some state
law that's been enacted
to try to raise the floor there.
The federal definition of
public use is just a floor
and states can go beyond that and restrict
the power of eminent
domain more forcefully
if they want to and they have.
- [Kim] So we've learned
that the takings clause
of the Fifth Amendment
prevents both federal
and state governments from
taking private property
for public use without just compensation
but there are a lot of
questions about what counts
as private property, public
use or just compensation.
In recent years, debate
over the takings clause
has centered on whether
government regulations
about how a private
individual can use land
also constitute a form of
compensation and the extent
of acceptable public uses for which
the government can seize property.
To learn more about the Fifth Amendment,
visit the National Constitution
Center's interactive
constitution and Khan Academy's resources
on U.S. government and politics.